Another important property
of graphs is connectivity.
That term has a specific meaning in the
study of graphs called Graph Theory but
let's define what it means for
a graph to be connected first.
A disconnected graph has some vertex
that can't be reached by the other
vertices.
A disconnected graph might have one
vertex off to the side with no edges.
It could also have two
so-called connected components,
which are connected graphs on their own
but have no connection between them.
Thus, a connected graph has
no disconnected vertices.
There's also a metric used to describe
a graph as a whole called connectivity.
Let's look at two different graphs and
say they're each describing
a different group of friends.
When looking at these two graphs,
the one on the right looks like
a much stronger friend group.
There are overall less people but
more connections between them.
In the left group I could
remove one connection and
the whole group would be destroyed.
This is the principle
behind connectivity,
which measures the minimum number of
elements that need to be removed for
a graph to become disconnected.
Depending on the information in
the graph, you can sometimes use
connectivity to answer the question
which graph is stronger.